i'm going to start with gronk
i i still have faith in gronk even
though it looks like he's running in mud
mixed with butter mixed with molasses he
had a great catch on sunday in traffic
he it was the kind of catch he hadn't
made earlier in the season when there's
other bodies and arms around i just
think he's getting his legs back and i
don't know how fast he's gonna be but
just the whole thing about being
comfortable on a football field again
after you close that book on your life i
feel like it's coming back for him and
they need him oj howard's out for the
year with a rupture to kill his tenant
so get me gronk yeah i i hear that i
mean he he did like look better moving
last week certainly and and you're right
i don't know you know that i can speak
to experience when you've been out of
the league or you just haven't been able
to play it's weird once you get back in
there you're like you're it's it's like
whoa i you feel like you've never done
it before it's not like just riding a
bike and being like oh wow this is easy
once again no there is a little bit of a
grace period and getting the body used
to it and everything like that all right
i'll go with deshaun watson as my first
pick you know not that it's
you know i'm really why do i think he'll
turn around because he's desean watson i
think he's talented i know that you know
it's not looking like they're going to
make the playoffs and things like that
but
i'm still going to bet on the person
that he's going to start playing better
football and it hasn't been great
football from him it's been a little bit
all over the place they need to help him
there's no doubt about that but i think
with him
and then you know the receiving core
obviously not being up to what i thought
it could possibly be it's still better
than what it's showing at this point and
as you've mentioned many times i mean it
was murderers row how they started the
year schedule wise and from that
standpoint i think it would be easier
too because you're not going to have to
play some of those teams again
curious to see what the lift is going to
be from the interim coach romeo cornell
i had the texans defense on my list i'm
not going to make them one of my picks
but i think that defense is going to
step up now that their guy has taken
over the team and and that may give them
a little a little kick in the butt
they've got the jaguars this week and
and and i think they can turn things
around they can't get much worse than
they've been next one for me is emmanuel
sanders
emmanuel sanders has been a
disappointment so far for the saints but
once michael thomas comes back
and defenses are obsessed with covering
michael thomas and trying to neutralize
michael thomas that's when things are
going to open up for emmanuel sanders
without thomas there
it's not like sanders gets neglected the
way he would if you're obsessed with
thomas and camara right right uh it's
going to get easier for sanders when
thomas is back and and sanders had that
touchdown catch
in the week three sunday night game
against the packers he said that was the
moment that it started to click and i
think it's gonna click even more when
thomas is back thomas will get his
numbers but i think sanders is gonna be
an even bigger contributor once thomas
is back and things are easier for him
yeah hopefully that kind of got things
started for them uh last week and what
they did i mean emmanuel sanders
certainly looked good and drew brees
seems to be more and more comfortable
with him and yeah they made a few plays
in the pass game and i you know you know
i think it's it's much needed they need
that other guy just to take some
pressure off like what you're saying
when michael thomas does come back you
know and defense is no man it's michael
thomas at alvin kamara you know to have
a guy like emmanuel sanders still be a
mismatch issue for for you know other
defenders uh that'll be big
all right um
i
i'm gonna cheat here but like i don't
care it's still i wanna go the 49ers
football team turnaround candidates i
mean they're two and two
yeah but i mean i i'm they're ravaged by
injury i still look at the team to go
yeah even the guys that you know i know
there's some that are lost for the year
and aren't coming back but the ones that
are ir and that are coming back and you
know some came back last week they're
getting healthy i just still look at the
49ers as being one of those teams with
shanahan's coaching and the talent they
have there and i know it's no nick bosa
that'll hurt but i still think there's
enough there that they can make a
serious run here in the nfc now they
might dig themselves into a hole where
they can't win the nfc west or maybe be
that one seed that gets the buy but
they're a team i look at to just go they
just got to get in the tournament and if
they get in the tournament and they're
somewhat healthy i still say watch out
for the the 49ers football team
you know i thought about going with kirk
cousins for my last one uh and there's
an argument to be made that he will turn
it around because dalvin cook is running
well and the natural progression is the
passing game will be easier to run and
justin jefferson is emerged quickly
after a couple of weeks where the entire
team looked like crap but i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go with le'veon bell
whoa not as a member of the jets i think
he's going to get traded
and i think he's going to get traded to
a team that's going to use him that has
the offense in place to benefit from him
and he's going to turn it around as a as
a member of some franchise other than
his current franchise in new york jets
and it's obvious they don't need him
it's obvious it's time to move on once
he's healthy i think he gets traded and
maybe he does something good this year
chris yeah i i i you know i had some
trade candidates on on my thing as well
just to sit there and go
all right like i thought about the same
thing with aj green i won't go there uh
but i like that levy on bell one and i
would expect that he does get traded and
they they kind of ripped the band-aid
off of that one um
all right i'm gonna go with the seahawks
defense here uh the yeah the unit itself
i mean it first off like you said like
you were talking about the texas defense
it can't get any worse but i'm gonna bet
on pete carroll and ken dorton jr and
some of the guys they got on that
football team that they right the ship
you know first off they got one of the
best run defenses in football so it's
top three now pass defense it is
horrible um but i got to think and i am
just going to play the percentages of
the guys they got up there jamal adams
he's led up a lot of big plays in the
past game because he's still learning
things and everything like that that
they'll write that to a degree to where
if they could just get in the top 20 in
past defense that'll be a big big deal
and a huge change for their football
team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports